continuer malgré tout malgré les bombes
et la mitraille pendant de longs mois
des femmes bosniaques ont résisté à leur
façon à la guerre qui mettait leur pays
à feu et à sang elles ont tricoté et
confectionné des robes qui viennent
d'être présenté lors d'un défilé à
l'UNESCO à Paris sur cette collection
très particulière Nicole cornulanglois
et Mar
Richard dans ce défilé toute la tragédie
bosniaque chaque maille de ses pulls de
ses manteaux est une parcelle d'espoir
et de survie ces mannequins venus la
plupart de Bosnie-Herzégovine portent
les modèles que leurs mères leurs sœurs
leurs amis ont tricoté pendant la guerre
dans les cave sous les bombes comme un
défi elles ont eu peur elles ont pleuré
mais maille après maille elles ont
tricoté leur avenir si leur modèle
arrive sur le marché européen c'est
grâce à une styliste amela vilic
diplômée des Beaux Arts de sarevo son
atelier de couture créé en 1984 n'a
jamais cessé de
fonctionner j'ai travaillé avant mais
surtout pendant la guerre
pour montrer à nos ennemis que nous
n'étions pas
abattus c'était une question de dignité
et je n'ai rien changé dans mon style au
contraire je l'ai
affirmé modèle abordable vendu aux
environs de 500 francs achet fait partie
de cette chaîne de
solidarité le tricot est l'une des
activités traditionnelles des paysan
bosn comme le tissage en valeur dans
cette exposition d'artisanat
venu avec ses enfants John malkovic
d'origine youoslave est particulièrement
concerné par cette
manifestation chaque fois qu'il vit une
histoire si triste si tragique si
horrible l'être humain tente de créer
pour
compenser quelquefis il échoue mais
qu'importe il
Ess
la mariée n'est pas en noir mais les
femmes bosniaques n'ont pas encore
retrouvé l'insouciance elle lance un
message d'espérance aux 70 millions de
femmes déplacées dans le
monde